that was Chuck Todd from earlier today
now back in our studio I'd like to
introduce you to icy Smith he's a former
Special Agent in Charge in the for the
FBI has just written a book here's the
cover of it it's called inside a top
g-man exposes spies lies in bureaucratic
bungling inside the FBI how long were
you an agent over 25 years and what what
years from 1973 to 1998 and why did you
decide to write this book I was actually
encouraged to by an old friend of mine
John Baron who's a author and former
senior editor a reader's digest this
occurred after I had testified on
Capitol Hill before senator Thompson's
committee at the time about campaign
finance violations so he can call me and
he said you should think about writing a
book as I said well I would do it and I
had never thought about writing a book
of this nature but I said I will do it
but with only the idea that I was going
to write it completely candid but also
if I thought I could add to the
discourse about some of the historical
events that I was around and stuff like
that and finally maybe to put a human
face on the FBI an organization it's
often viewed as some part of monolithic
jackbooted in stepped organization which
is not the case at all it's a very
diverse organization diverse politics
ethnically and what have you do they get
a bum rap does the agency get a bum rap
well I think at times but at times
certainly and there's some of the things
that I bring out in the book is it's
deserving of the criticism it receives
certainly don't think like 9/11 to what
degree is the the when they when there
is something bungled is it in a certain
area is there a problem in intelligence
is their problem in information is it a
people problem largely it's the latter
if when I look at 9/11 and the failures
of 9/11 and and I come down pretty hard
on the FBI because the FBI failed
American people that's just the bottom
line is that regardless of all the
structural changes that are occurring in
Washington the creation of new
bureaucracies and things like that the
bottom line was there was a failure
management it was at the lack of
information that the FBI had
that could have prevented 9/11 take us
to the time when you were in Arkansas
what year I was there from 95 to 98 as
the special agent in charge for the FBI
for the state of Arkansas and what was
the case that you spent a lot of time on
there no my goodness one of the things
that I did when I went down is and this
is incumbent upon any one who is in
charge of a particular area with FBI if
you conduct a crime survey and over the
period of several weeks and particularly
myself when I talk to community leaders
law enforcement personnel and things of
this nature is that I concluded that the
the primary role for the FBI should be a
rather systemic corruption within the
the politics of Arkansas itself I made
public corruption the highest priority
now this was during the time of
whitewater Ken Starr had just been named
as the independent counsel
and I had to make sure that our
investigations did not overlap with one
oh there had to be a virtual wall put up
between our investigations now don't get
me wrong
there was interaction I mean the first
day I was in the office Ken Starr came
to see me but it was a it was a made
public corruption the highest priority
and that was what I dealt with let me
take go back to your training now
because on page 17 of your book you say
you talk about Quantico and you say my
training there was a breathe both
academically and physically is that
going to surprise some people well you
got to remember that I was I was a law
enforcement officer before I went there
and and and I like to say and I can say
this with all candor is that I learned
very little about investigations from
the FBI I had been a homicide detective
and then what have you but what I did
learn from the FBI of course was the
administrative issues and things like
that you deal with when to a new
organization physically I was prepared
when I went there also you say here that
most FBI agents never have to pull their
weapons I think that's true another is
another misconception by the American
people
that probably a misconception but there
is it's important to note though that
FBI agents receive the training that in
those instances that they do pull their
weapons they are prepared to use it
correctly us understand how the agency
how the FBI is is structured we know it
here in Washington from the top but what
happens after it gets outside of
Washington well and I think part one of
the things that's happened under the the
new FBI that it's probably not is
decentralized the once was my impression
is and it's just an impression based
upon my conversations with FBI personnel
and just observations is that there is
greater control of the FBI field offices
now than it was in the past now when I
was in Special Agent in Charge is that I
had a great deal of autonomy from the
standpoint of being able to establish
priorities within our division and in
the conduct of the investigations
themselves my impression is those days
are gone and I think it's to the I think
it's probably not a good thing not a
good thing not a good thing even though
in the aftermath of 9/11 part of the
problem was that there was some
information sitting out there about
possible terrorists that didn't get back
to the central no in fact I was used to
the contrary is that the field officers
performed admirably if the the
collecting of evidence if you look at
the information it was from Phoenix and
Minneapolis and Oklahoma City and the
things this nature the breakdown was the
bureaucracy it it FBI headquarters but
how do you how do you combine all that
information from all those different
places without some kind of strong
centralized place the system would was
in place but it was mismanaged
the FBI is no different than the CIA and
the NSA and the DIA is that it's much
better at collecting information than it
is putting it to use this was a case
that the FBI had all of the information
it needed but where there was a formerly
had been a analytical entity in place
that this information would been
funneled to that had been somewhat
destroyed and so the information was not
getting there if you look at the tote
the information if the FBI had available
going back to 1995 with operation vote
gingka where they talked about this is
information out of Manila where they
talked about flying an aircraft into CIA
headquarters well I changed everything
because and I can remember vividly being
told about this bit of information and I
told the person who told me that this
changes things
because in 1993 they set the bomb in the
World Trade Center and they Iran but
here they were getting ready to
sacrifice their own lives to crash into
CIA headquarters so you combine that
with the totality of the information
that we had the information with the
French were talked about flag flying an
airplane into the Eiffel Tower the
concerns in Phoenix the concerns and in
Minneapolis the concerns in Oklahoma
City you had all this information at a
preoccupation with aircraft information
was there we could open up our phone
lines by the way and you can join us in
this conversation you'll see those phone
numbers at the bottom of your screen we
had just a earlier in a and an open
phone segment talk to the loot about
this piece which is in the front page of
the Washington Post and also the New
York Times about a report that came from
the FDA FBI who's saying that they they
were they were very critical of the way
detainees at Guantanamo were being
treated and also this was interesting
several agents FBI agents contended that
military interrogators were
impersonating FBI agents what's your
reaction to this story
this is absolutely reprehensible in in a
nation of laws that we have where we
talk about the rule of law where you
have this sort of misconduct and that's
just no other way to get around and it
was absolute misconduct now what I find
interesting about this and this is some
of the things that I haven't seen in the
the media to this point if this story
continues to seep out this information
went back to FBI headquarters clear
that's the case the report from the FBI
agent with this stuff in it went back to
the head went back to headquarters but
what did director Muller do with it that
he did he you know
a street agent can make a complaint to
some general and is probably not going
to have a lot of clout but the question
is gonna have to be asked is what the
director Muller doing this information
did he weigh in on it
it doesn't appear that he did and that's
wrong how many agents out there write
reports I mean we're I'm just trying to
get a feel for the volume and what comes
in goes up to the very head of the
agency and how does it get his attention
his or her attention well one of the
great myths numbers is that when it says
director FBI that doesn't mean if the
director actually see that it's just FBI
headquarters and it funneled into the
correct unit or section back at FBI
headquarters but you would assume that
this information did in fact go to the
director and certainly to his caproni
who is the the chief counsel now a lot
of these this sort of thing it appears
from the article that they were
responding to requests from FBI
headquarters to put down their
observations at least some this year's
report and apparently someone back there
someone at FBI headquarters had cause
for alarm so they went back out and he
says what happened out there so these
guys came back and he probably told them
more than they wanted to hear this and
this is what I go what goes back to I
talked about the diversity of the FBI
agents and stuff like this these guys
are not going to cover-up at all they're
going they're gonna tell it just like it
is the problem is the street-level guys
they're gonna tell it like it is it's
not only the case where the headquarters
bureaucrats well I asked you this
because in a New York Times article they
say that it appears it's possible rather
that there was a wide circle of
government officials who knew about this
I suspect that's the case now what what
let's say what the question that has to
be asked though is what the director
motor in this caproni the the legal
counsel had a legal counsel there what
did they do with this information
did they weigh in with the depent agon
did they go to the Attorney General I
don't know the answer to that
our guest is icy stone he has a new book
out book was actually published I think
earlier this fall November the 18th and
he is here to join us to give us some
insights into the I'm sorry
I said stone didn't I I meant Smith I
see Smith who gives us some insights
into the FBI let's take some of your
phone calls Raleigh North Carolina good
morning good morning Agent Smith good
morning I have my question and it's
going to be what what is what did your
investigation find out then I'm going to
make a comment and I'm going to explain
my comment my own investigation into the
Chinese Charlie tree johnny chung fiasco
there was that these guys were right
wing operators out of Taiwan they were
more likely Republican operatives and
the reason I say that is I mean I ran
across pictures of Newt Gingrich and
Johnny Chong and cheek to jaw their
connections in Taiwan were basically all
right wing people the corporations that
they fronted the money to the Clinton
administration were from dubious sources
this money had to be given back by the
Democrats how they found out I guess do
the operators and the Republicans I got
let me just explain it this way here's
the scam you know you're you're
basically in control of Congress you're
investigating an administration your
operatives gave them the money bomb
Democrats have to give the money back
you use the full weight of the Congress
to to instigate this investigation you
know that when I watched the hearings
you know I mean I just couldn't believe
that the Clinton administration would
sell us out to the Chinese and you know
later on well I was the the technology
transfer between a democratic
contributor and a Republican contributor
specifically Hughes and I forget that
the Democratic conservator
but basically Hughes was convicted in
the end and the people that the
Democratic contributor was not convicted
could you explain that to the viewer
well thank you of from the standpoint of
the investigation that I heading out of
Arkansas we had almost nothing to do
with Chung himself the our investigation
centered around Charlie tree and John
Wong one of the one of the gets real
disappointments of any investigation and
this happens with all of us through our
careers is that when we have an
investigation that is concluded
prematurely and I think this is probably
what happened with the the campaign
finance investigations as it turned out
at perhaps at the time that appeared
before senator Thompson's committee in
September of 99 that was really kind of
the the last splash of any consequence
when you had four FBI personnel sitting
up there criticizing the Department of
Justice and the FBI for the miss
handling the lack of aggressiveness in
conducting this investigation as it
turned out though at the same time that
the the Republicans were wanting to cut
off funding to Senator Thompson's
committee the Democrats really had no
real interest in pursuing this thing any
further and basically the Department of
Justice was not aggressively pursuing it
so I basically you ended up with an
investigation that concluded somewhat
prematurely one of the other things that
you have to talk about in accepting the
money is that you the ideology of I
think the Clinton administration was
primarily want a reelection no more so
than any other issue and money drives
re-elections Baltimore
hey good morning morning thank you I'd
like for the gentlemen II responded to
ideas first there in the sixties the FBI
had in Freedom of Information Act
information quote the FBI is saying we
try to quote prevent the emergence of a
black messiah or basically swart
the civil rights movement with the exact
same tactics tenth we've legalized
through the Patriot Act that's number
one number two with respect to jet with
respect to the information I agree with
them
we did have information on 9/11 a
possible 9/11 attack and al Qaeda attack
and it was John O'Neill one of the
senior senior men in the FBI in New York
when they came into the when he can't
win first came into the into office his
investigations of al Qaeda were thwarted
by the State Department which is one of
the record is one of the reasons John
Adair left the FBI and became president
I'm head of security at the at the trip
at the World Trade Center and burned up
in the entire an entire fiasco here's my
point this administration basically
forwarded the investigation of John
O'Neill of al Qaeda
why don't we never see any of these 19
hijackers donor to the in explains why
don't any of these play why none of
these players ever been seen in
slowmotion
going into those buildings because a Fox
News reporter reported that it wasn't
even a commercial plane it was a it was
a plane with no windows similar to a
remote control air tanker we'll leave it
at that I see Smith well first of all in
four four is the 1960s and in the FBI
and I'm not ducking your question here
when I tell you that was a little bit
before my time and it's interesting that
I can certainly sympathize from the
standpoint of the Freedom of Information
Act I have the same problems that you do
or anyone else does and getting
information out of the FBI probably the
single worst agency in government to get
information out of as far as the is John
O'Neill of course I write about him in
my book and he was something of a
Renaissance man and he was a fellow that
probably didn't have a great deal of
background dealing with terrorism
matters but he was one of those also
that was a very very quick study and but
John could be terribly difficult to work
with certainly he could be harsh on his
subordinates probably even abusive at
times and one of the things that I think
that happened was is that John was a guy
that was when he went over to you to
Yemen he
adhere to the diplomatic niceties that
sometimes we expect a certainly the
State Department expects and so you had
a clash of cultures and while John came
back after he was basically thrown out
of Yemen and conducting the
investigation he came back and he was
kind of lauded around the FBI as being a
real hero because he stood up to the
State Department well what happened was
that that's good on one hand but on the
other hand the investigation was lagging
there was nothing occurring during this
time so no one won on that sort of thing
about how many agents do we have in
foreign countries around the world and
well when when I was in the FBI we only
had like 20-something offices I was a
legal attache in the South the city and
I understand now is closer to 50
countries so I would suspect we have
several hundred in any given time now
that doesn't count the ones that we have
in places like Afghanistan and Iraq and
certainly I guess even Guantanamo so
it's a pretty large contingent of the
FBI personnel around the world and what
about the whole idea of jurisdiction and
whether the FBI should be doing anything
outside of the borders of the United
States well it that that part of it has
a change now the FBI can operate under
what's called extraterritorial
jurisdiction but you only do that with
the
the consent of the host government when
I was a legal attache in Australia New
Zealand Papua New Guinean Cook Islands
and all those sort of places is that I
went to those countries I had to notify
I'm certainly the ambassador or someone
there if they knew I was coming I didn't
go out and knock on doors and talk to
anyone and it's had someone with me so
you do that with the consent of the host
country so it's extremely important that
FBI personnel have those skills that
allow them to establish some sort of a
cooperative relationship when you're
sorry and and and and and this has it
always occurred is that we have to be
very very sensitive we we certainly
wouldn't want someone from a foreign
country coming over here and knocking on
the doors of Americans and and doing
questioning and that sort of thing same
thing applies to working over there as
you're doing foreign investigations do
you have to notify the CIA since they
would be the international intelligence
organizing group well there's a
cooperative relationship and in frankly
I'm a little bit perplexed by this lack
of cooperation between the CIA and the
FBI because that was never my experience
it at all and I cite examples in the
book here for example when General
Rafael del pino defected from Cuba the
very first person I called was my
counterpart at CIA before even called
FBI headquarters that as well in purely
law enforcement related issues a murder
investigation or white-collar crime or
something like that I don't think it's
absolutely necessary to tell the CIA
what you're doing but as a matter of
courtesy sometimes you do that because
they have their own sources and methods
that that you can maybe put to use
Washington DC your next good morning
go ahead Washington hello you're on the
air yes one support the president but I
was wondering why when you mentioned in
your opening statements about 9/11 you
were not asking any questions about what
was known about 9/11 there in the there
in the studio were there black boxes
discovered what government agencies or
what people were at the
fAA on that day was there a government
or non-government exercise in a setup
that was a plan to to encase planes went
into the any buildings was some exercise
going on that day that we haven't been
told about mr. Smith hmm well I should
point out that I was actually retired at
the time of 9/11 actually when the first
planes hit the World Trade Center I was
actually even working on this manuscript
so I really don't know the full extent
of the investigation only this what
though as well Roger said I know what I
read in the papers and that's kind of
where I am on this thing I'm really not
sure about black boxes and advanced
knowledge and things of that nature I
want to go back to a caller in our
earlier segment this morning who called
and in chastised some some of the other
colors saying you know Americans want to
know too much that at this time when we
are in under such a terrorism alert that
we have to we have to believe that there
are things out there that the FBI is
catching and that we're never going to
know about it would you agree with them
well I can only agree with that to a
degree to the to the point that you
don't want to do anything of premature
disclosure that would harm a criminal
investigation or some sort of
intelligence issue or something like
that but on the other hand I'm a firm
believer of the First Amendment and and
I'm one of those that have great concern
that even it has an FBI agent and even
today a great concern with the this
obsessive secrecy that we have i I kind
of come down on the side that I think
there's probably more government
incompetence and and and misconduct
hidden behind secrecy than they are
national security secrets themselves if
for example and I think this was his
example a a bomb was found wrapped in
anthrax and the FBI was able to to catch
it ahead of time or Homeland Security
was able to catch it ahead of time
should that information go out at some
point
that's about
perhaps not in the mediate aftermath
because of investigation itself you know
you an investigation has a rhythm and
you have to kind of follow that rhythm
it's something like a music sheet and
what-have-you and and and you is you
follow that investigation you have to
conduct your interviews and that sort of
thing but it's some point there I think
it's very very important that American
people are made aware of what has been
occurring let's go to Woodbridge
Virginia next good morning good morning
seas bango-ru sir good morning sir I
have to tell you that I studied the
September 11th attacks and a lot of
people have a lot of questions
pertaining to that day I would like to
know if you knew it the Secret Service
didn't trust George Bush card at school
on September 11th like they were
supposed to and I like to know why
because an through car was burning hot
George Bush's ear at a miracle is under
attack two planes hit the World Trade
Center in America's under attack he
didn't say America was under attack he
didn't say New York and DC were under
attack he said America is under attack
so why was it George Bush Russia started
out school I don't have a clue sir
and and and and I can say in all I stood
that I haven't talked to a single Secret
Service agent since the 9/11 attacks or
have any insights into that I was
somewhat perplexed I think a lot a lot
of people but the initial reaction of
just sitting there and then but I have
no explanation for that my gut feeling
is that the president was probably just
sitting there waiting to receive a
little bit more information because the
only thing he received was there's been
a plane that crashed in the World Trade
Center at that particular time I don't I
doubt seriously that they had
information that would suggest that it
was a terrorist act I will tell you this
that when I was sitting there working on
my manuscript and as soon as I heard I
had on one of the cable networks and as
soon as I heard that there had been a
crash I knew immediately it was never
naina doubt in my mind that it was
terrorism
but I'm not I can't say the same for the
president Paso Robles California Smith
I'm a staunch Republican and I have a
question about all those emails that
occurred when Al Gore was running for
president and there was supposed to be
an indication that they had taken you
know under the table money Chinese money
and all the emails were going to prove
it we never heard anything more about
that that's my point number one point
number two
Sandee burgers pilfering the archives of
top-secret documents never heard a word
about that follow-up so I'll take your
answer offline but don't know if either
of those have anything come under you at
all or you have any experience with in
my investigation there again charlie
tree John Wong emails were not a part of
the investigation and the miss the
burger is incident my assumption is
still under investigation
Los Angeles good morning good morning um
I'd like to ask you said you worked in
Arkansas politics you were looking for
corruption there I can't help but wonder
when I hear stories like putting bugs on
Bill Clinton's brother friend to get
information so that they could indict
him for something I can't help but
wonder how much time was taken up by
Louis Freeh and the FBI to investigate
the White House and everybody connected
with the White House in the 90s and they
didn't spend enough time to keep this
911 from happening I mean I I keep
thinking that if they had had their eye
on that ball that 9/11 wouldn't have
happened
I see Smith
the investigation into corruption in
Arkansas at no point during my time
there involved the the president or even
his brother the investigation that I was
pushing involving people like the local
prosecutors sheriff's the state
legislators the whitewater investigation
was kept separate and distinct from
those being conducted by the FBI office
and so I I really can't I really can't
address the issue of bugs on President
Clinton's brother or anything like that
it didn't happen on my watch
Long Island hello yes mr. host I'm sorry
I forget your name but I would like to
point out first of all it's easy if you
even think about not asking for
information
your whole c-span and news organizations
can just throw out there which they
almost have done already anyway before
out their whole mandate for being in
existence second of all to the staunch
Republican in California yes mister
Berger was totally cleared of all
charges and was buried in there like
fifty thousand page of the newspaper try
reading the newspaper cover to cover and
second well mister mr. Smith I would
like to know how is it possible that the
president is allowed to be a traitor in
office by filming and making a sworn
oath to protect and defend the
Constitution of the United States but
yet personally violate that oath by
having people sign stupid affidavits to
attend his rallies and and give up their
rights to freedom of speech and freedom
of association you please answer that
we'll leave that as it is caller I don't
think that has anything to do with what
our guest knows about Vienna Virginia a
good morning how are you doing mr. Smith
and Madam I wanted to comment since the
FBI has jurisdiction on American soil
and the CIA has outside jurisdiction
what happened during the eighties when
the CIA was selling crack in New York
and Los Angeles where would the FBI call
are you still there
thank you okay I have to go there again
has nothing to do with the book but I
think I can respond to that in part a
lot of this came from a single reporter
that was attached to the Sacramento Bee
as I recall and
his investigation has been largely
discredited period there was never any
evidence that the CIA and that's
absolutely erroneous Tevan suggested to
CIA would be involved with the selling
of crack cocaine on the streets of Los
Angeles did the FBI had to approve your
manuscript before it was printed yes
rather tortuous process well what is
like what was it like
initially the FBI has 30 days to respond
to a manuscript of this sort something
that actually I was involved in when I
was still at FBI headquarters previously
reviewing other people's mention yes
they have 30 days the FBI in this
particular case came to me after about
three weeks and asked for a two-week
extension to because I had they said I
had pushed the envelope beyond where
they'd not have been accustomed being
pushed so what I did is I said sure
give him the two-week extension I want
to cooperate well actually they didn't
even make that two-week extension but
they came in and they had 85 objections
to my manuscript that was a new record
I'm told
so I imposed a 72-hour rule on myself
before I responded because I wanted to
do it without a great deal of passion
and anger sat down wrote a response to
every single objection included things
like affidavits executive orders news
media releases actual quotations from
other FBI authors the books that they
had written and things of this nature
went back my appeal was about three
inches thick and it took almost a year
then to get it out then and I basically
beat them on more than 80 at 85
objection there was a couple of things I
conceded it was easy to do at one point
they called me and they said that the
the Larry Wutai chin chapter they had
sent it over to the CIA for their review
I said well you should have called me in
advance but go ahead well about a week
later they called and they said CIA
wanted to see the complete manuscript to
put the Larry Wutai gen chapter in
context well I said you know the CIA has
no way
corruption in Arkansas and things of
this nature I had no problem that CIA
was basically very easy to work with in
that regard and it was finally released
so I then went back and I added a cup of
chapters one of them dealing with Robert
Henson for example then I added the
chapters dealing with 9/11 so I had to
go back through the review process with
mr. case it was much easier than the
first time around and you said you used
to do this yeah some of this and when
you were an agent so how did you see it
from now seeing it from both sides of
the fence well one of the things that
had happened is the executive order had
changed that governs the disclosure of
classified information and and basically
what happened is if President Clinton
had written an executive order which
bottom line was you had argued on the
side of disclosure has a on the side of
maintaining the secrets if it's a close
call type thing so I was a little bit
different from that from that standpoint
but I found that that there a lot of
their objections were just absolutely as
kind of astounding for example they
didn't want me to use the direct
quotations from our public testimony
before senator Thompson's committee
things of that nature kind of silly
actually our guest is IC Smith the
former special agent in charge and this
is his book inside a top g-man exposes
spies lies in bureaucratic bungling
inside the FBI it is published by Nelson
current must be one of the very first
books published by that imprint it's
actually the second one the second one
thank you very much for joining us this
morning it's been a real pleasure
appreciate it